So I want to talk about Harriet Tubman and
the promise that the Treasury Department made
a few years ago before, uh, the Obama administration
went out.
Uh, they made the promise that she was going
to be on the $20 bill by 2020.
Um, yesterday, Steve Mnuchin, uh, secretary
of the treasury basically punted down the
field at least a six years saying that if
it happens, it's only going to happen in 2026
and it's not going to be a anything that he
will have responsibility for.
A take a listen to this clip.
Do you support Harriet Tubman being on the
$20 bill?
I've made no decision as it relates to that
and that decision won't be in it.
And as I said, tell him to sex.
There was a national, there was a, a community
process.
Uh, again, it's a decision of the secretary
of the treasury.
Right now my decision is focused on security
features.
And what about imagery?
What about the representation?
It again, it's not a decision that is likely
to come until way past my term, even if I
serve the second term for the president.
So I am not focused on that at the moment.
No, I'm laughing.
I'm laughing because even notes and said I'm
not getting it to this.
You can because obviously, um, conservatives
would lose their mind.
I, I Paul's, let me say this.
Um, I have to operate in two channels at all
time to wavelengths, links at all time because
I really don't care if, if Harriet Tubman
is on the $20 bill, I don't think Harriet
Tubman would even want to be on the $20 bill
of a nation in which she was born when it's
sold.
Right.
Using that same currency or the, the, you
know, the, the ancestor recurrency whatever.
I don't care.
But the point is, hey, tell me would not want
to be apart of this American capitalistic
system.
Right.
She was a product of it.
I believe that she would look at this and
say, you know what I mean with a, with a very
stern look and say, y'all lost your damn minds.
So me personally, I didn't, I never cared
for the idea.
And then the, the other wavelength that I
have to operate in is like, okay, I get it.
Representation 100% matters.
And I only say it, I only say it like that
kind of, um, you know, with a solemn resolve
because you know, it does matter.
Like, you know, the more images my daughter
gets to see of of black women doing things,
the more it makes her proud to be black, the
more she, uh, she sees a women doing great
things, the more she believes that she can
do it.
Like I'm literally seeing that happen before
my eyes.
I don't know if any of you have children,
but representation matters.
And for us, for so many of you, um, you never
had that problem because you know, you ever
saw on television was people who look like
you.
Well, that's not always been the case for
black people.
So I'm, I'm, I have this like this fight warring
in my mind at any given time with most issues
because honestly, who the hell cares?
I mean, American capitalism is one of the
number one problems that we have across this
globe.
When you think Harriet Tubman, the, the, the
woman who, who, who, who, who set so many
slaves freed and have said even more free,
if they knew they were slaves, you think she
gives a damn about being on the $20 bill?
I think she would be repulsed by the idea.
I think she would be more interested in challenging
America and challenging American imperialism
presently.
Right?
If we moved her up to date, she wouldn't argue
about a $20 bill.
She would argue over American imperialism,
she will argue over American capitalism and
how it's still exploiting people across the
glow, still getting essentially slave labor
just by another name.
That's what she would care about the same
time.
My little girl definitely needs to see some
representations.
So I, I have both these, these things, this
dichotomy and my brain go and get any given
time.
So there's good about this, there's bad about
this, but what I love about this minutian
said, I am not putting myself in the middle
of this fight, which he knows conservatives
will lose their mind.
Conservatives would absolutely, I mean, I
wish I could cuss on this program, come to
my podcast and I'll just say it the way I
want to say it, but they would go back crazy
over the fact of us replacing, uh, Andrew
Jackson on the $20 bill.
I believe it's Andrew Jackson, right?
One of the most evil, I mean, destructive,
belligerent, drunken blood, thirsty monsters
in American history for home.
Donald Trump is a big fan, right, of whom
Donald Trump is a big fan.
They would lose their mind of us, take it
for us if we rather take him off of the $20
bill and put Harriet Tubman.
And so Steven Mnuchin said, you know what
the hell with that?
I'm kicking, I'm putting this down.
Um, I'm putting this down the field.
And no matter how many times represented a
Ayanna Pressley, who I, I know, uh, how many
times she asked him differently?
He said, nope.
He said, look, even if I'm here for a second
term,
I'm not touching it.
Um, or you know what, I don't blame